alors bon la question c'est aussi où
est-ce que vous en êtes avec joey starr
est là aujourd'hui c'est un peu statu
quo il ya des gens qui essaient de vous
réconcilier non pas vraiment ah ben non
je suis là vous êtes tâche est on est on
est pas vraiment fâché on a eu un peu la
vie a fait que c'est un peu séparés et
qu'on a les environnements un peu
différent et que c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on se côtoie plus trop
combien d'années ensemble ensemble
ensemble ça fait vingt ans quand il fait
de la télé réalité pour canal vous
réagissez comme en vous je m'en fous un
peu
un ouais hein c'est pas ce que je ferais
je m'en fous il était dans la ferme
jamais facile et elle serait passée de 3
trucs comme pas il se passe vraiment pas
grand chose mais je sais par un jeu trop
mais franchement ça aurait été top
ouais je suis la ferme un peu anthony
non je regarde pas beaucoup la télé moi
alors je l'expliqué